hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic
chemist and big fan of vitamin c
vitamin c is one of the most raved about
ingredients in skin care and there's so
much evidence to back up its effects but
it's also one of the most confusing there
are just so many different vitamin
c ingredients and product types and
that's before you get down to all
the different products you can buy
so this is going to be a bumper guide to vitamin
c and i'm going to have to split it into two
separate videos in this one i'm going to focus
on the form of vitamin c with the most evidence
ascorbic acid and it also happens to be the
fussiest drama queen i'm going to be talking about
what it does how to use it the different product
types and some product recommendations in part
two i'm going to talk about the other versions of
vitamin c the derivatives these are great if your
skin is too sensitive for ascorbic acid or you
just can't handle how confusing ascorbic acid is
so why is everyone so obsessed with vitamin c
in skin care? well it's because of the amount
of evidence behind it it's one of the best
studied ingredients in skincare in the grand
hierarchy of skincare ingredient categories
if retinoids were up here vitamin c would be
maybe around here just below it and specifically
its ascorbic acid we're talking about ascorbic
acid is the best studied and most common type
of vitamin c you'll find in skin care products
it's actual vitamin c the same stuff
you find in oranges and in supplements
a side note sometimes you'll see people say it has
to be l-ascorbic acid and not just ascorbic acid
the reality is pure l-ascorbic acid is the
cheapest kind of ascorbic acid you can get so
all the ascorbic acid that you find in skincare
and supplements is going to be l-ascorbic acid
l-ascorbic acid has been found
to have these effects on skin
it can increase collagen in the skin this is
probably the most exciting effect vitamin c is
involved in making collagen and cross-linking
it so that it makes a nice firm solid network
some of the enzymes involved in this prolyl
and lysyl hydroxylase need vitamin c to work
vitamin c might also be able to block the
action of matrix metalloproteinase 1 this
is an enzyme that breaks down collagen
in the skin it can also help with wound
healing such as after you have a fractional laser
treatment and it also boosts pigment reduction
and that's the other big skincare
concern that vitamin c can help with
it can reduce pigments such as sunspots
and post acne marks and melasma
ascorbic acid interferes with the production of
melanin which is the brown pigment in your skin
the exact way it does this still
isn't entirely confirmed but it
interferes with the enzyme tyrosinase
and stops it from doing its job properly
vitamin c can also help protect skin from sun
damage it doesn't stop uv like sunscreen but it
acts as an antioxidant that mops up the damage
that uv does inside your skin one of the big
reasons uv is bad for skin is that it produces
free radicals i have another video that goes
into detail about free radicals and antioxidants
but basically free radicals are really reactive
substances that smash into lots of different
parts of your skin causing generalized damage
sort of like a bull in a china shop antioxidants
can soak up this damage provided they can actually
get into your skin where the free radicals
are and ascorbic acid can get into your skin
in one of the classic pig skin
vitamin c studies they needed
twice as much uv to turn skin red
after it had been treated with 15%
l-ascorbic acid adding 1% vitamin e doubled that
and adding 0.5% ferulic acid doubled that again
meaning that this combo gave a total
of eight times the uv protection there
were similar results when vitamin c was used
with ferulic acid and phloretin on human skin
vitamin c has also been shown to reduce some
of the skin damaging changes that infrared
radiation can cause in your skin there's also
evidence that can protect against ozone and
diesel exhaust which are two pollutants
you find in urban areas also in some of
these studies they found that people who didn't
get enough vitamin c in their diet had bigger
improvements in their skin so unsurprisingly
a balanced diet is good for your skin
so how do you use an ascorbic acid product
studies have generally tested ascorbic acid
products at between 3 and 25% and like for many
other skin care actives i think lower percentages
are actually underrated higher percentages can
be really irritating and a lot of studies have
actually used lower percentages like three and
five percent so you don't actually have to go
very high to see benefits out of all the skincare
ingredients i think ascorbic acid is definitely
one where you can get diminishing returns if you
go too high i'd recommend starting at under 10%
and then going up or down depending on how that
goes you might even need to stop it all together
because a lot of people do find ascorbic acid
too irritating there are also some fruits that
are very high in ascorbic acid so for example
kakadu plum is about 12% ascorbic acid by dry
weight but usually with fruit extracts it can
be really difficult to work out exactly what
percentage you have because extracts vary a lot in
terms of how concentrated they are so if you want
something more reliable i'd recommend looking
for a product that has straight ascorbic acid
with layering i'd recommend
using ascorbic acid as close
to your bare skin as possible so one of
the first steps after cleansing because
it's not very good at getting into skin ascorbic
acid can go with most other skin care products
the only hard no's i can think of are copper
ions so any of those blue copper products
and benzoyl peroxide both of these will inactivate
the ascorbic acid it's a myth that you can't use
ascorbic acid with niacinamide kind of stephen
has debunked this thoroughly on his blog
i recommend being careful with other irritating
skincare ingredients like hydroxy acid exfoliants
and retinoids they can go together but you have
to be really careful otherwise you'll burn your
face off actually there's one more ingredient
incompatibility that i discovered when i used
them together on my face and that is i had an
eyebrow pencil that went bright orange when i
used it with ascorbic acid it had ferric ammonium
ferrocyanide in it so be careful with that one
you can use vitamin c morning or night if
you use it in the morning you'll probably
get more of those uv protection benefits
but it's believed that vitamin c has a depot
effect so in other words one application
lasts more than 24 hours in your skin
in pig skin it was 72 hours so using
it at night will probably get there too
it is a myth that vitamin c is photosensitizing
it will actually improve your resistance to uv
i think this myth comes from the fact that
alpha hydroxy acids are photosensitizing and
then people assume that all acids were but in
fact no acids are apart from alpha hydroxy acids
now the big problem with vitamin c is there is so
much variation when it comes to vitamin c products
not all forms of vitamin c have been shown to have
all these amazing beneficial effects in human skin
some might have had one effect in a study
but it wasn't very high quality study so you
can't really say much for sure some of them
are pretty unlikely to work at all and with
every variation it depends a
lot on the specific formula
here's where i'm going to introduce the lab
muffin matrix for figuring out whether or not
a skincare product will actually work i'll
talk more about this in a later video and
to be honest i haven't really fleshed it out
properly but these are some of the things you
want to be thinking about you want to see if
the active ingredients can theoretically work
and if the active ingredients have been shown to
actually work on human skin in clinical trials
a lot of things that could theoretically work
don't actually work when you put them on a
complex system like human skin if everything that
theoretically worked actually worked on humans
then we would have cured cancer thousands of
times over you also want to see if that specific
formula could theoretically work and then if it's
actually worked on human skin in clinical trials
some ingredients are really easy to
formulate with so you don't have to do
too much guesswork here but other ones
are a lot trickier cough ascorbic acid
there are a few really annoying things about
l-ascorbic acid firstly l-ascorbic acid is
pretty unstable and it breaks down relatively
quickly to inactive dehydroascorbic acid when
it's been ionized this happens faster when
it's in water when it's at a high ph so when
it's alkaline and when it's exposed to
light and oxygen this process is called
oxidation because oxygen is usually
involved this means your product gets
less effective over time and how quickly
this happens depends a lot on the formula
when it breaks down it starts off colorless
then it goes yellow then orange than brown
so you can sort of get a visual indication
of how active your vitamin c probably is
so looking at the lab muffin matrix L ascorbic
acid ticks off these two boxes really well there
are tons of studies on it or at least tons
of studies by cosmetic ingredient standards
but it's in these two other boxes
where things get incredibly dicey
and it's largely because of this instability
how much ascorbic acid you actually have depends
so much on the formula the packaging and how
long you've had it it is probably one of the
trickiest ingredients for this part on top of
whether or not it works decomposed vitamin c is
just plain annoying because it stains after the
ascorbic acid breaks down a few times it turns
into a chemical called erythrulose this is
a component of fake tan and that means your
decomposed vitamin c can stain your
face and your skin this isn't harmful
but it's also not designed to be a fake
tan product so it doesn't go on very evenly
and it gives you that metallic soy sauce sort
of smell and this decomposition speeds up after
you've applied it to your skin obviously your
skin is going to have more oxygen and more light
than in a bottle so even a very stable formula
can give you nasty stained yellow fingers for days
ascorbic acid is usually formulated
to be at a relatively low ph below 3.5
to help it get into the skin when
the ph is higher then more of the
ascorbic acid will be charged and charged
things don't get into skin very easily
this was actually the topic of my very first
youtube video having a low ph also helps
keep it stable and sometimes the ph is lower
than it needs to be because of legal reasons
moving on to the different formulation
types let's start with ce ferulic
the best researched ascorbic acid formulation
is the skinceuticals c e ferulic formula
the scientist who did most of the peer-reviewed
research on vitamin c's effects on skin was dr
sheldon pinnell he patiented a particular
formulation and his son started the
skincare company skinceuticals
which is now owned by l'oreal
the patent which is commonly called
the duke patent is pretty broad as
well as covering the ceo of rylic formula
which was the formulation developed from
all of these studies into vitamin c it also covers
any formula with pure ascorbic acid at 10 to
20 concentration and a ph between 2 and 3.5
so in other words the formulations where vitamin c
seems to perform best now these aren't really hard
and fast rules a lot of the early studies were
done on pig skin and it isn't like it doesn't work
at lower percentages there are clinical trials
where three and five percent worked really well
anyway this is why scientists and dermatologists
always rave about the skinceuticals c e ferulic
formula this is literally the formula that's the
culmination of all of this ascorbic acid research
it's really rare to have a non-drug product that
scores really well in all of the boxes on the
lab muffin matrix this product basically does
the best out of all the skin care products that
aren't regulated as drugs they've subbed out the
vitamin e to make it less oily and thick and so
it works better for oily skin there's phloretin
cf which is recommended for discoloration and
silymarin cf which is recommended for oily acne
prone skin and again there's lots of studies on
these which means they get good marks in all
of these departments the obvious downside is
that these are really expensive not everyone
wants to pay this much or can pay this much
even if it is the gold standard rolls royce
of all vitamin c products slash all non-drug
skincare products and it still does eventually
break down it's not a hundred percent stabilized
they say it's fine for six months after opening
the patent suggests that it'll be fine for more
than a year so what are the other options you
could look for a copycat vitamin c vitamin e
and ferulic acid serum there are some that violate
the patent and l'oreal just haven't gone around to
suing them yet and there are some that get around
the patent by messing around with the formula for
example some of them go outside the ph range
that skinceuticals has bagsed with their patent
some of them might go lower than
the already pretty extreme ph range
and i think that's why some people
think their skin can't handle vitamin c
as a scientist who worked in r&d i know how
important patents are in getting companies to
invest in innovation so i'm a bit ethically
conflicted about trying to work out which
products do and don't violate the patent so i'm
just going to list a bunch of popular products
that have vitamin c e and ferulic acid there's
timeless paula's choice maelove geek and gorgeous
and ausceuticals i recommend you look up reviews
to get a gauge of which one might be right for you
are they as good as the skinceuticals ones?
well obviously the overall formula doesn't have
the same level of evidence but anecdotally from
people who have tried both some people find the
skinceuticals formula much more gentle and more
effective whereas other people can't really tell
the difference so i think it really depends
on how picky your skin is and what you want
out of a vitamin c product for shorter term
effects like pigment then anecdotal evidence
is going to be a bit more useful for longer term
effects like collagen production you're probably
going to want more clinical evidence because
it's hard to see what's going on just by eye
you could also track down the ingredients and
diy something very similar to the skinceuticals
formula by following the patent michelle is not a
lawyer do not trust her do not take this as legal
advice she is not responsible if l'oreal break
down your door and sue you for patent infringement
this is a bit of an investment both time and
money wise but it could pay off if you commit
to doing it so if you're not sure whether or not
your skin even likes vitamin c then it's probably
not as good an idea if you want to go down this
route holy snails has a tutorial on her blog
there are also lots of other antioxidant combos
that work apart from just vitamin e and ferulic
acid this combo is mostly what dr pinnell
published his peer-reviewed research papers on
which is why everyone uses it but even in the
original patent this wasn't the only combo
there are tons of combinations in the patent and
there are a million antioxidants out there so
some of them will definitely work as well also
ferulic acid is mostly what's causing that hot
dog water smell there's a bit of vitamin c in
there as well but it is mostly the ferulic acid so
if you hate that smell then it might be worth
looking for one that doesn't use this combo
i recommend looking for a product where the brand
has tested it out properly in terms of stability
and clinical results because now the lab muffin
matrix is looking a bit sadder on this side one
example of a good one would be the ultraceuticals
one i'm sure there are others out there
it's also possible to stabilize ascorbic acid
in other ways you can use special airtight
packaging unfortunately a lot of airless
pumps aren't actually airless so they don't
protect the vitamin c properly from oxidation
it's also difficult to find pumps that don't
have metal springs in them and that metal
will rust and decompose with the vitamin c
so that means your packaging breaks plus that
extra metal will deactivate vitamin c faster
but it is possible to get special packaging
that works for example the rohto melano cc
has a special airtight tube you have to squeeze
it really hard to get any product to come out
you can also use colloidal gold i know colloidal
gold sounds really gimmicky but they have some
really cool applications in drug delivery this is
basically getting substances where they need to
be to work which is very relevant to skin care
someone in my phd research group was actually
studying gold particles the way it works is
ascorbic acid is bonded technical word conjugated
to tiny gold particles the ones used in skin
care are generally just too big to be categorized
as nanoparticles the gold also has glutathione
on it which is another antioxidant it's almost
like a vitamin c derivative except it's still
listed as ascorbic acid in the ingredients list
the extra bond stabilizes it and the ascorbic
acid doesn't come off the gold particle until
it's in your skin so that means it's fine at a
higher ph the manufacturer recommends 3.5 to 6.5
and because it gets into your skin a lot more
easily and it's a lot more stable that means a
lower percentage of ascorbic acid bonded to gold
will be as effective as a higher percentage of a
regular ascorbic acid product there are products
from naturium and murad which use this technology
there are also vitamin c derivatives
which is a whole different kettle of fish
i'll go into more detail about those
in part two of my vitamin c guide
so that is water-based ascorbic acid products like
i mentioned ascorbic acid is pretty unstable when
it's dissolved in water but what if we get
a product where it's not dissolved in water
where you maybe dissolve it yourself that means
you don't have to worry as much about how long the
product's been sitting around waiting decomposing
before it gets to you or even going through some
pretty gnarly destabilizing temperature changes
there are a few different categories of these
products there's the very simple diy formula that
i talked about in an earlier video i forgot to put
on my lab coat this formula is super basic with no
penetration enhances and you're probably going to
have to remake it every few weeks or so because
it does break down plus the only preservative
is the low ph but because it's so fresh a lot
of people do see better results with this than
an older pre-made more stable vitamin c serum
this is the cheapest option but it does take time
i've had a lot of questions about this
diy serum some people have claimed that
it couldn't possibly work but i don't think
those arguments make much scientific sense
having the ascorbic acid crystallize out after
you've put it on your skin isn't a big issue i'll
talk about this in a bit but solid ascorbic acid
crystals can work on skin ascorbic acid is stable
enough to last a few months after you've dissolved
it this has been reported in the literature and
i've done a few experiments myself to see how long
it lasts so i'll talk about that in a later video
i've also had a lot of questions about adding
things to it like glycerin and aloe vera
i generally wouldn't recommend it because there's
no extra preservative here it's at a very low ph
which means that there's a low microbial risk
but if you start adding stuff into it that feeds
bacteria and fungi that's going to up the risk
so i'm not really comfortable recommending that
same with keeping it for a longer period of time
like it could be fine but there's also a good
chance it won't be so if you do try that be really
careful and don't say i didn't warn you michelle
is not responsible if you make this and mess up
your face she bloody warned you if you do want
to make it more complicated i recommend checking
out that holy snails blog post and tweaking that
there are also products where the ascorbic acid
comes as a separate powder and it's already
pre-measured and you just dump the whole lot into
a base serum drunk elephant recently came out with
one there's also been some from the body shop
and clinique so those are also an option there
are also just jars of ascorbic acid powder that
you can buy and you dissolve a little bit into
your serum right before you apply it the ordinary
has one and i don't really like these i've talked
about why before you need a really tiny amount of
ascorbic acid per application three drops of a 10
vitamin c serum converts to 1/50th of a tic tac
and that's really hard to measure out that means
it's really variable how much you're applying you
could be applying too much like forty percent plus
when you just dissolve the powder without
adjusting the ph afterwards then you generally end
up with a much lower ph than you want it's going
to be more irritating so i'd warn against doing
that it might be okay if you have really resilient
skin or if you put it on thicker body skin
maybe if you mix it into a really soothing product
but i think there are much safer options that
won't mess up your barrier also if you decide not
to listen to me and do it anyway it's probably
cheaper if you buy nutritional ascorbic acid and
a mortar and pestle so you can grind it up finely
there are also water free products these
have ascorbic acid but it's ground out really
finely and then suspended into an oily base
ascorbic acid doesn't ionize an oil so it's
pretty stable like this then when you apply
to your skin it slowly dissolves in the water
that's always evaporating off your skin this
is where trans epidermal water loss comes from
this is also why the so-called crystallization
of ascorbic acid isn't a problem when you're
doing a diy serum ultraceuticals have published a
peer-reviewed paper on what i'm assuming is that
ultra c23 plus firming concentrate this has the
ascorbic acid in a silicone base and it's had a
lot of those really nice vitamin c effects on
tiny skin samples l'oreal revitalift 10% pure
vitamin c serum is another good one a lot of the
time when it's a really big brand like l'oreal
you can probably assume they've tested it there
are a few other brands that have had similar
products too like the ordinary and paula's choice
there are also a couple of pre-made ascorbic acid
and silicone ingredients that can be used to
formulate these sorts of products really easily
the biggest problem with these is that the
ascorbic acid crystals aren't dissolved yet
and there's generally no ph adjusters in them
so when these tiny crystals of ascorbic acid do
actually dissolve you end up with tiny puddles
of really concentrated ascorbic acid at low ph
on your skin and some people's skin is fine
with this but a lot of people including me
we do get a bit of stinging and irritation so i
like to mix it with another product in my hand
before applying it to try to get that ascorbic
acid to dissolve and get a low concentration
before it hits my skin i usually use the paula's
choice 2% bha liquid for this but it might be too
much for a lot of people's skin because double
acid so maybe use a toner the downsides are that
the texture can be really tricky again mixing can
help and sometimes it's still too much for some
people's skin i wouldn't recommend these sorts
of products at all if your skin can't handle a
regular water-based ascorbic acid product but if
your skin can handle them and you want a product
where you can leave it in the corner for a year
and it'll still be good this is a great option
this is one category that i almost forgot actually
there's probably tons of categories i've forgotten
but microneedle patches with ascorbic
acid inside the solid needles
after you apply the patch the ascorbic acid
in the needles go into your skin a little
bit and then they dissolve there acropass
spot eraser and zitsticka hyperfade both
have ascorbic acid in them but it's not really
the star ingredient these are only really good
for spots like acne marks and they usually have
other pigment fading ingredients in them as well
so that is seven or eight separate
categories of ascorbic acid products
let me know if i've missed any and that's just
ascorbic acid so far i'm going to come at you
with ascorbic acid derivatives in part
two these are good options if you don't
like the smell or staining or irritation or
stability issues of ascorbic acid but you
do sacrifice some of that guaranteed efficacy
in the first column of the lab muffin matrix
like subscribe follow check out my other videos
check out my blog check out my exfoliation guide
and skincare guide if you haven't already and
i will see you next time for more nerding out